[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
que los lleva a dar una vuelta al mundo
de la mano de nuestra red de periodistas
Zoe herminia Fernández empezamos en
Colombia donde aparecieron los cuatro
niños indígenas que se perdieron durante
40 días en la selva del guaviare a pesar
de tener solo cuatro nueve Trece y un
año los menores consiguieron sobrevivir
en la selva y muchos se preguntan Cómo
Alba Santana tiene los detalles
es una historia que ha sorprendido al
mundo entero la supervivencia de cuatro
niños en la selva del guaviare Colombia
tras 40 días ha perdidos el primero de
mayo el avión en el que viajaban se
estrelló en la mitad de la selva pero
los menores de cuatro nueve Trece y un
año sobrevivieron
el dispositivo de búsqueda dio con
pruebas de ello como un biberón fruta
mordisqueada o huellas pero a pesar de
estar muy cerca no consiguieron
encontrarlos hasta el 9 de junio y lo
más sorprendente con vida estaban en la
Vereda Palma Rosa a tan solo 5 km de
donde se estrelló su avión y a pesar de
tener signos de desnutrición con buen
estado de salud en general algo que hace
saltar una pregunta cómo lograron
sobrevivir 40 días en mitad de la selva
la respuesta se encuentra en la
cosmovisión indígena del mundo y la
conexión que tienen con la naturaleza
los grupos indígenas colombianos
aseguran que la misma selva los protegió
o que posiblemente se encontraron con
grupos no contactados a presentes en la
región además los niños del pueblo
indígena huitoto en especial los dos
mayores sabían manejarse por la selva
la sobrevivencia de los niños es una
muestra del conocimiento y
relacionamiento con el medio natural de
la vida el cual se enseña desde el
vientre de la madre los indígenas no
entienden el mundo igual y según su
cosmovisión en la selva nunca se pierde
nadie es un tránsito del que se puede
volver o no un episodio que según dijo
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
quedará en la historia del país
la destrucción de la presa de kahoovka
ha afectado gravemente a uno de los
afluentes del nieper el inmunette que se
desbordó e inundó Campos y pueblos a más
de 50 kilómetros al norte de gersón un
equipo de France 24 recorrió parte de la
zona afectada con el jefe de la
Administración militar
enjurisca un cargo equivalente a un
alcalde en tiempos de guerra veamos la
historia
[Música]
Iván cucta alcalde de nijurisca evalúa
con franqueza la situación en la zona
Julio malísima la situación es mala
Este es el río inhuluez que en este
punto suele tener 80 metros de ancho y
está atravesado por dos puentes hoy
kuxta necesita una lancha rápida para
llegar a las comunidades repentinamente
aisladas de la otra orilla allí la
espera lleven el líder de la aldea
llevo dos días suplicando a la gente que
evacue pero me dicen que no que no voy a
salir de mi casa que prefiero subirme al
tejado que no quieren ir a ninguna parte
a pesar de que sus casas ya están bajo
el agua
es la abuela la que no quiere irse
intentamos convencerla pero no quiere
mi marido y yo trabajamos mucho tenemos
tres vacas y un toro y dos terreneros
trabajamos mucho por los niños
levantarse y dejarlo atrás no sé es duro
para el alma
[Música]
incapaces de persuadir a las víctimas de
las inundaciones para que se vayan
preguntan qué pueden traer cuántos niños
pequeños hay aquí que necesitan comida
para bebés actualmente No hay ninguna
carretera accesible para salir de estos
pueblos cuyo sea residentes ya
soportaron meses de ocupación rusa y
bombardeos queremos dirigirnos al mundo
entero buena gente mira lo que está
pasando
fue nombrado jefe de la Administración
militar cuando se liberó la zona en
noviembre
no pensé que el agua fuera a llegar tan
alto todos los pozos están inundados con
esa agua inutilizables
se ha descubierto que las aguas de la
inundación contienen varias toxinas en
cantidades peligrosas
hay escasez de agua porque todos
nuestros pozos están en la llanura
aluvial de la cuenca del Río y nuretes y
están inundados
las cosas podrían empeorar aún más una
de las muchas tareas urgentes de cupta
es asegurarse de que el agua sucia no
contamina una importante estación de
bombeo cercana que abastece a cientos de
miles de personas en nicolaib y gerson
el pasado junio se celebró el Día
Internacional del doblaje en España es
una seña de identidad desde los años 30
que mueven los 100 millones de euros al
año y emplea cerca de 5.000 personas
pero la irrupción de la Inteligencia
artificial preocupa a Los profesionales
del doblaje por sus posibles impactos
como también lo ha hecho en otros
actores de la industria en Hollywood
también se han quejado por lo mismo las
voces de esta historia están en el
reportaje de nuestra corresponsal en
Madrid Marina Colorado
quiero empezar de cero ensayan para
hacer las próximas Voces del doblaje en
España y Luis erra es quien los guía por
este arte que ha cambiado mucho en los
últimos años desde la pandemia por
ejemplo los guiones impresos se quedaron
obsoletos
preparaba tres guiones por película por
documental y ahora todo lo tenemos Ya
digitalizado no esto es lo que van
trayendo lo que es o sea lo que trae y
lo que conlleva las nuevas tecnologías
en este caso pues bueno pues mucho mejor
una nueva tecnología está poniendo en
alerta a la industria la Inteligencia
artificial Pablo Fernández cofundador de
varias empresas de ia asegura que los
actores no desaparecerán pero sí tendrán
que reinventarse probablemente los el
trabajo de los dobladores a futuro no
será repetir o leer lo que pone en un
texto sino será dar instrucciones a la
Inteligencia artificial de quiero que me
dobles esto sonando como este actor no
Hazme este Matiz Entonces pasas de ser
un hacer un director de Orquesta
Raúl se prepara para reunirse con los
directores de doblaje de videojuegos que
forman parte de adoma sindicato de
actores de doblaje de Madrid que él
preside son parte de la iniciativa y un
airet voice arest este grupo global de
sindicatos de actores pide transparencia
en los contenidos generados por
Inteligencia artificial y una
compensación por derechos de autor el
resultado que va a dar va a ser porque
ha cogido la interpretación
de pues x decenas cientos o miles de
actores y actrices las Ha deformado
hasta que ninguno sea reconocible y se
inventa un timbre según los parámetros
que le estén dando es una simulación
hecha con un montón de interpretaciones
que pertenecen a alguien
autores invisibles que temen ser
sustituidos y que levantan la voz y
esperan que las únicas iniciales y a en
la industria del doblaje sean las de
inteligencia artística
hace tres años científicos del Instituto
de Ciencias del mar de Barcelona
realizaron un asombroso descubrimiento
encontraron muy cerca de la ciudad en un
área contaminada las gorgonias un tipo
de coral blando que se considera
particularmente resistente al
calentamiento global los investigadores
se sorprendieron de hallar esta especie
que está en peligro de extinción Y
decidieron usarla como parte del intento
para revitalizar el hecho Marino más en
el siguiente informe
y nos pidieron a presupuesto al icm a
escasos metros del puerto de Barcelona
buceadores voluntarios y científicos se
dan cita cada mes para explorar el fondo
Marino vale chicos Pues nos preparamos y
vamos al agua es bióloga ya ha venido a
tomar algunos esquejes de las gorgonias
al igual que los corales duros que están
en peligro de extinción estos fueron
descubiertos accidentalmente hace tres
años en las aguas de la capital catalana
un misterio de la naturaleza y una
fuente de Esperanza para los ecologistas
del día
forman verdaderos bosques marinos son
como los bosques de tierra pero están
formados por animales muchas especies
ponen sus huevos o se refugian entre
esas ramificaciones vale como aquí en
Barcelona tenemos caballitos de mar o
muchas especies de peces es sorprendente
que estas gorgonias no en un área tan
impactada
para llegar al fondo del Enigma Joseph
María y otros biólogos marinos iniciaron
un proyecto de investigación
el hecho de que proliferen en Barcelona
han adquirido una capacidad tratativa
importante al cambio climático con lo
cual es un ejemplo desde el punto de
vista biológico ecológico extremadamente
interesante y importante no por las
próximas tres a cinco semanas yo separía
y su equipo van a cultivar gorgonias
para estudiar su resistencia ambientes
contaminados
en los fondos de Barcelona tengamos un
auténtico bosque de gorgonias esto es
realmente único enorme Mediterráneo y
espero con el futuro otras ciudades lo
puedan estos científicos dicen que es
vital conservar y regenerar los fondos
marinos de Europa los mares y océanos
del mundo producen al menos el 50% del
oxígeno disponible en la tierra
Gracias por acompañarnos en
corresponsales nuestro agradecimiento es
a casa magola por ser sus instalaciones
para grabar el programa el día de hoy
siga con France 24 y France 24.com